let's take you live now to pennsylvania
where democratic presidential candidate
joe biden is speaking at a campaign
rally
he's paid 50 times more in taxes in
beijing
than he's paid in america that's a fact
he has hundreds of millions of dollars
in debt
over 400 million during the next few
years who's he owed to
where's it coming from he's the only guy
and if it's known as president who's
making money from foreign sources
folks give me a break this guy's not on
the level he thinks wall street built
this country
but you and i know who really built this
country
families like mine working people build
the middle class
and unions built the middle class
folks we're so much
better than this we can bring back this
economy it starts with my plan to deal
with this pandemic responsibly
bringing the country around to testing
and tracing and masking
social distancing not politicizing
the race for a vaccine planning for its
safe and equitable distribution
everyone gets it providing for funding
to open our schools and our businesses
safely
the ppe national standards
bringing together republicans and
democrats deliver economic relief for
working families
in schools and in businesses a majority
want to do that even
those are there now
as i said before i'll shut down the
virus
not the economy and we can walk and chew
gum at the same time
we can build back better than before
an independent analysis by moody's a
wall street firm
looked at my plan and his plan in detail
this is moody's
and they said my plan will create
18.6 million jobs in the next four years
that's seven million more jobs and one
trillion dollars more in growth than the
president's plan
and that comes from wall street and
moody's
here's how my plan works
none of you will have your taxes raised
anyone making less than 400 000 will not
see a penny in taxes raised you'll
actually see your
standard of living go up and your costs
go down
and why i'm going to do this i'm going
to ask big corporations the wealthy to
pay their fair share
right now of the fortune 500 companies
there are 91 who don't pay a single
penny in tax
if they just paid 15 instead of the 28
they should that would raise 400 billion
dollars
allow me to send every single qualified
person
to community college if that's what they
chose so democratic presidential
candidate joe biden speaking in
pennsylvania at a rally and as you heard
him say that his plan is to shut down
the virus and not
the economy